ثمن
الحقيقه انهار البرج انهار البرج لكشف هذه
الحقيقه ووضعها امام الجمهور ثمن لم
يتوانى ابناء الجزيره عن
دفعه الاعتقال الابتزاز
التنمر
السجن التعذيب الافتراء التلفيق القتل
التضييق التهديد بالقصف
والقصف كل هذا واكثر تعرض له ابناء مهنه
الاوجاع وما
يزالون الاحتلال يرتكب مجزره جديده مجزره
جديده نفذتها الطائرات الحربيه
[موسيقى]
الاسرائيليه درب تبدل فيه دماء وكثيرا ما
يكلل بالشهاده العافيه كل الصحافيين كل
[موسيقى]
الزملاء واينما حطت كاميرا الجزيره ومد
فيها الميكروفون ينقل اهات المضطهدين حول
العالم وكيف تاثر من حولهم من اقرباء
[موسيقى]
واحباء مننا في
الاد
معلش الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه القت
برميلا متفجرا على المنزل الذي تتواجد فيه
عائلتي ما ما ادى الى استشهاد جميع افراد
العائله هو قدر الصحفي والعاملين في
الاعلام ممن تبنوا القضايا العادله نهجا
ونبراسا
[موسيقى]
ورساله نريد كشف الحقيقه ويريدون طمسها
لكن انا لهم ذلك عزاؤنا
الوحيد اننا
[موسيقى]
مستمرون